et la parole est maintenant à Monsieur
Laurent Burgaud à pour le groupe les
républicains merci
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre la Fédération Française de la
course camarguaise et sous la tutelle du
Ministère des Sports et après les
corridas ce sont dans notre traditions
camarguaises qui sont menacées en effet
dans une tribune de publier dans le
journal Le Monde une cinquantaine d'élus
animalistes ou écologiste donc 11 du
conseil municipal de Montpellier ont mis
le feu à la Camargue et à la Petite
Camargue emilite pour l'abolition des
lâchés de taureau dans nos rues la
suppression de l'utilisation d'un
crochet lors des courses camarguaises
mais aussi des ferrades et de l'escosur
nos festivités camarguaises représentent
au-delà d'un enjeu économique certains
un enjeu culturel important pour de
nombreuses communes dans les
départements du Gard mais aussi de
l'Hérault des Bouches-du-Rhône et du
Vaucluse madame la ministre avant le
grand rassemblement en faveur de
traditions camarguaises prévues le 11
février prochain à Montpellier ma
question est double quelle est la
position du gouvernement face à ces
menaces et apportez-vous votre franc
soutien à nos traditions je vous
remercie
merci
pour vos réponses pour vos réponses la
parole est à Madame Rima Abdul Malak
ministre de la Culture
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Burgoa je crois qu'en 2 minutes
je ne vais pas pouvoir embrasser toutes
les dimensions soulevées par votre
question surtout que en tant que
ministre de la Culture je pensais vous
répondre sur le dossier UNESCO porté
pour inscrire au patrimoine immatériel
les courses camarguaises et toutes les
traditions qui sont associées bon en
fait vous n'en avez pas parlé mais je
voulais vous dire que ce dossier et je
vous en parle puisque je suis ministre
de la Culture
et que j'en profite aussi pour saluer le
travail qui avait été fait en 2021 par
les sénatrices Catherine Dumas et
Marie-Pierre Monnier sur le patrimoine
culturel immatériel tout ça est lié à
votre intervention puisque ce patrimoine
culturel immatériel il comprend les
pratiques les représentations les
expressions les connaissances les
savoir-faire mais aussi tous les
instruments les objets les artefacts les
espaces culturels qui leur sont associés
voilà pourquoi
récemment nous avons obtenu
l'inscription des savoir-faire de la
baguette de pain dont nous sommes très
fiers
et oui et juste vous dire
juste vous dire le nom de dossiers qui
arrivent tous les jours
et qui nous intéresse aussi non mais
parce que tout cela montre la la
richesse la diversité des traditions
locales qui font partie du patrimoine
français mais je veux citer aussi
d'autres dossiers qui sont importants le
carnaval de Guyane le biou d'Arbois
fête annuel vitivinicole dans le Jura
les couvreurs zingueurs de Paris Lorie
Tahiti une pratique polynésienne
culturelle sociale très important les
Jeux floraux de Toulouse non mais c'est
l'occasion d'en parler messieurs et
mesdames les sénateurs
joue de poétique depuis 700 ans voilà
pour ce qui est de cette richesse du
patrimoine culturel immatériel français
[Applaudissements]
allez allez allez on se calme on se
calme bon allez un peu de calme monsieur
Burgaud a vous avez 53 secondes pour
nous parler l'UNESCO merci monsieur le
Président je ne vous en veux pas vous
madame l'administrature mais je regrette
que la ministre de tutelle madame la
ministre des Sports ministres de tutelle
de la Fédération Française de la course
camarguaise vous n'avez pas été donné
répondre madame les gens de la Bouville
vont apprécier cela alors que c'est vous
votre ministère de tutelle alors mes
chers collègues en 1926 à la demande du
marquis forcal barroselli le peintre a
représenté la nation camarguaise avec sa
désormais célèbre trois cabrises elle
représente nos gardiens et nos pécheurs
et incarnent trois vertus la foi la
charité et l'espérance le peuple de
Camargue espère que ces traditions
perdureront malgré les attaques de ces
entités
allez
[Applaudissements]
allez allez
merci